today we're going to talk about search I
know you got turned blue with the add
another lecture on search those of you
who are taking computer science subjects
you've probably seen it in 601 you'll
see it again a theory course so we're
going to do something we're going to do
it for a little different purpose I want
you to develop some intuition about how
various kinds of search work and I want
to talk a little bit about search as a
model of what goes on in our heads and
toward the end if there's time I'd like
to do a demonstration for you of
something never before demonstrated to a
6:03 for class because it was only
completed last spring and some finishing
touches were added by me this morning
always dangerous but we'll see what
happens
so there's Cambridge you all recognize
it of course you might want to get from
some starting position s to some goal
position G so you'll hire a cab and hope
for the best
so here's what might happen
not too hot let's move the search
position over starting position over
here I've had cab drivers like this in
New York but it's not a very good pass
it's a it's the pass of a thief let's
change the way that the search is done
to that of a beginner an honest beginner
not too bad now let's have a look at how
the search would would happen if the cab
driver was a PhD in physics now after
his third postdoc
these are not actually traverse these
are just things of the that the where I
was thinking about and that is the very
best of all possible paths so the thief
does a horrible job the beginner does a
pretty good job but not an optimal job
this is the optimal job that's produced
by the PhD in physics after a third
postdoc so would you like to understand
how those all work the answer of course
is yes so I want to talk to you about
procedures that are different from the
way that you solve just just solve this
problem I imagine that if I said can you
please find a path from s to G you would
within a few seconds find a pretty good
path not the optimal one but a pretty
good one using your eyes and we're not
going to tell you about how that works
because we don't know how that works but
we do know that problem-solving with our
eyes is an important part of our total
intelligence and we'll never have a
complete theory of human intelligence
until we can understand the
contributions of the human visual system
to solving everyday problems like
finding a pretty good path in that map
but alas we can't talk about that
because we don't know how to do it we're
working on it but we don't know how to
do it so I'm not going to use Cambridge
in my illustrations as too much too much
there to work through in an hour so
we're going to use this map over here
which has been designed to illustrate a
few important points so you two can you
find a path through that graph pretty
easily with your eyes but our programs
don't have eyes and they don't have
visually grounded algorithms so they're
going to have to do something else and
the very first kind of search we want to
talk about is called the British Museum
approach this is slur against at least
the British Museum if not the entire
nation because the way you do a British
Museum search is you find every possible
path so it will be helpful to have a
diagram of all possible paths on the
board so we're going to start with a
British Museum search and follow the
firing position
the starting position from the starting
position it's clear that you can go from
s to either A or B and already there's
an important quiz point whenever we have
these kinds of problems on a quiz we ask
you to develop the tree associated with
a search in lexical order so the nodes
there under s are listed alphabetically
just just to have an orderly way of
doing it so from a we can go either B or
D and another convention of the subject
another thing you have to keep in mind
in quizzes is that we don't have these
searches bite their own tail so I could
have said that if I'm at a I can also go
back to s but no path is ever allowed to
bite itself to bite itself to go around
and enter and and and and and get back
to a place it's already on the path now
if I go on to be first that means that I
could go here from from B I can go eat
to either a or C this is getting fat
pretty fast but let's see s a B the only
place I can go is C and then to e s ad
without biting my own tail and going
going back to a the only place I can go
is G s ba I can only go to D and then to
G and finally SBC I can only go to e so
that is the complete set of paths as
produced by any program that you will
feel you'd like to write that finds all
possible paths I haven't been very
precise about how to do that because you
don't have to be can't say much work by
being clever because you have to find
everything so that's the British Museum
expansion of the tree
so what have I done
I've been playing around with a map I
showed you an example of a map and
pretty soon you're going to think that
the search is about maps so before going
even another tiny step I want to
emphasize that search is not equal to
maps search is about choice and I have
to illustrate these searches with maps
because they are particularly cogent but
search is not about maps it's about the
choices you make when you're trying to
make decisions so these are choice these
things I'm going to be talking to you
about today are choices you make when
you explore the map you can make other
kinds of choices when you're exploring
other kinds of things and in fact at the
end of there's time I'll show you how
how you do searches when you're solving
problems in the humanities class all
right so that's the British Museum
algorithm search is not about maps
our first goal star idea search is about
choice but for our illustration search
is about maps so the first kind of
search we want to talk about that's real
is depth-first search and the idea of
depth-first search is that you barrel
ahead and a single-minded way so from s
your choices are a or B and you always
go down the left branch by convention so
as we go to a from a we have two choices
we can go to either B look you can go to
either yes B or D following our lexical
convention after that we can go to C and
after that we can go to E and too bad
for us we're stuck
what we're going to do we've got into a
dead end all is lost
but of course all isn't lost because we
have the we have the choice of backing
up to the place where we last made a
decision and choosing another branch so
that process is called variously backup
or backtracking so at this point we
would say ah dead end the first place we
find when we back up the tree where we
made a choice is when we chose B and it
instead of D so we go back up there take
the other route SB SS ad now goes to G
and we're done
so we're going to make a little table
here of things that we can embellish our
basic searches with and one of the
things we can embellish our basic
searches with is this backtracking idea
now backtracking is not relevant for the
British Museum algorithm because you've
got to find everything you can't quit
when you found one path but you'd always
want to use backtracking with
depth-first search because you may
plunge on down and miss the mr. Pathak
gets to the goal now you might ask me is
backtracking therefore always part of
depth-first search and you can read
textbooks that do it either way count on
it
if we give you a search problem on a
quiz will tell you whether or not your
search is supposed to use backtrack and
we consider to be an optional thing it'd
be pretty stupid not to use this
optional thing when you're doing
depth-first search but we'll separate
these ideas out and call it an optional
add-on so that's depth-first search very
simple now the companion did I mean the
natural companion to depth-first search
will be breadth-first search
Red's first in a way it works is you
build up this tree level by level and at
some point when you scan across a level
you'll find you've completed the path
that goes to the goal
so level by level s can go to either A
or B a can go either to B or D and B can
go to either a or C so you see what
we're doing we're going level by level
and we haven't hit a level with the goal
with it yet so we've got to keep going
note that we're building up quite a bit
of stuff here quite quite a lot of
there's quite a lot of growth in the
size of the path set that we're keeping
in mind at the next level we have B
going to C D going to G a going to D and
C going to E and now when we scan across
we do hit G so we found a path with
breadth-first search just as we found a
path with depth-first search now you
might say well why don't you quit when
you hit G implementation detail we'll
talk about sample implementation you can
write it any way you want but now that
we know what these searches are let's
speed things up a little bit here and do
a couple searches that now have names so
the type the first type will be
depth-first boom that's the one that
produced that produces the the thief
path and then we could also do a
breadth-first search which we haven't
tried yet
what he supposed going to happen this is
going to be fast slow produce a good
path produce a bad path I don't know
let's try it
I had to speed it up you see because
it's doing an awful lot of search it's
generating an awful lot of paths
finally you got a path is it the best
path I don't think so but we're not
going to talk about optimal paths today
we're just going to talk about pretty
good pass heuristic paths oh well let's
uh move the starting position here in
the middle do you think breadth-first
search is going to be stupid I think
it's going to be pretty stupid let's see
what happens it searches a lot to the
left which you would never do with your
eye let me slow that now just to
demonstrate it finds a shorter path
because it's right there in the middle
but it spends a lot of its time looking
off to the left it's pretty stupid
that's how it works so now that we've
got two examples of searches on the
table I like to just write a little
flowchart for how the search might work
because if I do that then it'll be
easier for us to see how what kind of
small difference there are between the
implementations of these various
searches so what we're going to do is
we're going to develop a waiting list a
queue a line whatever you like to call
it let's call it Q now to develop a
queue of paths that are under
consideration so the first step in our
algorithm will be to initialize our
queue and I think what I'll do is I'll
simulate depth-first search on this
problem like up there on the left using
this algorithm so I need to have some
way of representing my paths and what
I'm going to do is I want to betray my
heritage is the list programmers because
I'm just going to put these up as if
they were less path expressions so to
begin with I just have one path and it
has only one node in it yes that's the
whole path so the next thing I do after
I initialize the queue is I extend first
half on the cube okay so the when I
extend s I get two paths
I get s goes to a and I get s goes to B
so I take the first one off the front of
the queue and I put back the two that
are produced by extending that path now
after I've extended the first path on
the queue I have to put those extended
paths onto the queue I've in here
there's an explicit step where I've
checked to see if I that first path is a
winner if it's not I extend it and I
have to put those paths onto the queue
so I'll say that what i do is i NQ in QE
now I've done one step in this let me do
another step I'm going to take this
first pass off I'm going to extend that
path and where do I put these new paths
on the queue if I'm doing depth-first
search well I want to work with the
paths that I've just generated I'm
dictating this plunge down deep into the
in the search tree so since I want to I
want to keep going down into the stuff
that I've just generated where then do I
want to put these new paths at the end
of the queue don't think so because
gonna be a long time getting there I'm
going to put them on the front of the
queue so
for depth-first search I want to put
them on the front of the queue and
that's why s a B goes here that s ad and
then that's SB so SB still there that's
still valid possibility but now I've
stuck two paths in front of it both of
the ones I generated by taking a path
off the front of the queue discovering
that it doesn't go to the goal extending
it and putting those back on the kill so
I might as well complete this
illustration here while I'm at it I take
the SAV off s a B and I can go only
there to see but of course I keep s a D
and s B on the Q so now I take the front
off the Q again and I get s a b c e and
not to forget s ad and SB i take the
first one off the q doesn't go to the
goal i try to extend it but there's
nothing there I've got reached a dead
end so in this operation all I'm doing
is taking the front one off the Q and
shortening the Q we're almost home now I
take s ad off the Q and I get s a D G
and of course I still have s B but now
the next time I visit the situation I
discover buried in step here in that
first step I discover a path that ducks
actually does get to the goal of M done
so each time around
I initialize the cube I check to see if
I'm done if not I extend I take the
extensions and put them somewhere on the
queue and then I go back in and in here
there's a varied test which checks to
see if we're done so that's how the
depth first search algorithm works and
now what we have to start all over again
if we did breadth-first search
nope same algorithm all the code we've
got needs one line replaced one line
changed what do I have to do different
in order to get a breadth-first search
out of this instead of a depth-first
search
Tania and where do I put it on the cube
she says and change it put it on the
back so with breadth-first search all I
have to do is put it on the back and go
now if we were content with a
inefficient search and didn't care much
about how good our path was would be
done and we could go home but we are a
little concerned about the efficiency of
our search and we would like a pretty
good path so we're going to stick around
for a little while now you may have
noticed up there in that development of
the breadth-first search that the
algorithm is incredibly stupid why is
the algorithm incredibly stupid high
what do you think it certainly can't
tell whether it's getting closer or
further away from the goal and we're
going to deal with that in a minute but
it's even stupider than that why is it
stupid what's your name Sam nice bless
those it's extending paths that go to
the same node more than once let's see
what dill is talking about down here it
extends a but it's already extended a up
there down here it extends a path that
goes to B and it's already extended the
path that goes to B over here it extends
it it looks at a path it could extend
the path that went through C but it's
already got a path that goes through C
so all of these paths are duplicated and
we're still going through them so that's
incredibly stupid so what we're going to
do is we're going to amend our algorithm
just a little bit
and we're not going to extend the first
path on the queue or rather yeah we're
not going to extend the first path on
the queue
unless final node never before extended
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look to see if there we've got this
path and we're going to extend it and
it's got a final note if we've ever
extended the path that goes to that
final node and it was a final load on
that path and we're not going to do it
again so we got to keep a list of places
that have already been that have already
been the last piece of a path that was
extended grab that so awkward to say it
because it's it's the last node we care
about if a path terminates in a note and
if some other path previously terminated
in that note and got extended now we're
not going to do it again it's a waste of
time
all right now let's see if this actually
helps now use extended list let's see
well gee we got that place in the center
there let's just repeat the previous
search
Wow taking a long time but notice that
it did he put 103 paths back on the
queue now let's add the filter and try
again
a lot less so we'll speed this up and
we'll start way over here you remember
how tedious that search was and now
we'll repeat it with this this list boom
there it is that's all because we didn't
do that silly thing of going back
through the final mode a final node
that's already been gone through all
right so you would never not want to do
this now we better list this as another
option doesn't help with the British
Museum algorithm because nothing helps
with the British Museum algorithm does
it help with depth-first yes does it
help with breadth-first yes do we do
backtracking with breadth-first no
because we're looking
backtracking can't do us any good okay
so we're almost we're almost home except
that that search that started in the
middle still pretty stupid both the
breadth first version and the depth
first version are going off to the left
and we would never do that with our eyes
in that case so the next thing we want
to do is we want to have ourselves a
slightly more informed search by taking
into consideration whether we've seem to
be getting anywhere so in general it's a
good thing to get closer to where we
want to go so in general if we've got a
choice of going to a node that's close
to the goal or a node that's not so
close to the goal we'll always want to
go to the one as close to the goal and
as soon as we add that to what we're
doing we have another kind of search
which goes by the name of hill-climbing
and it's just like depth-first search
except that instead of using lexical
order to break ties we're going to break
ties but according to which node is
closer to the goal all right now I've
went to some trouble to talk to you
about this in queued lists and having
gone to that trouble I'm now going to
ignore it not because it isn't a good
idea
but because try to keep track of
everything in the example kind of kids
confused an example won't work out right
a small example and all that so put the
put the in queueing thing aside queued
lists aside and think instead just about
the value of going in the direction it's
getting us closer to the goal
so in hill-climbing search just like a
depth-first search we have a and B and
we're still going to list them lexically
on the under underneath the parent node
now which one is closer to the goal now
this time B is closer to the golden a so
instead of following the depth-first
course which would take us down through
a we're going to go to the one that's
closest which goes through B and B can
go either go to a or C right
yeah sure B is 6 units away from the
goal and a is about 7 plus not drawing
exactly the scale use the numbers not
your eyes so now what now where are we
as symmetric so a and C are both equally
far from the goal so now we're going to
use the lexical order to break the tie
so now from s B a will go to D and now
which is closest to the goal well it's
the only choice we have so now we have
no choice but to go down to the Gulf so
that's the that's the hill climbing way
of doing the search and notice that this
time there's no backtracking
so it's a little bit it's not that it's
not the alcohol path not the best path
at least there's no backtracking but
that's that's not always true that's
just an artifact of this particular
example so do you think hill climbing
would produce fast research I think so
so let's see you know what happens when
we add these things one of the time
first let's turn off our in queued list
our extended list I mean turned off our
extended list and we're going to do
depth-first again just for the sake of
comparison produces a very roundabout
path with 48 in queueing x' now let's
switch over to hill climbing what do you
think they'll produce a straighter path
fewer and cuing x' boom you wouldn't not
want to do that with you if you've got
some kind of heuristic that tells you
that you're getting close to the goal
you should use it now it's easy to
modify my example my example over there
so that so that getting close to the
goal gets you trapped and in a blind
alley on e that's easy to do but that's
just artifact of the example in general
you want to go along the path that gets
you closer to the goal so that's 23 I
don't know let's see if using the
extended list filter does any good yeah
still 23 so in that particular case the
in queueing list the the expansion
extension list didn't actually do us any
good because we're kind of driving
sososo directly toward the goal okay so
that's that now let's say is there any
analog to what we might say that this is
yet another choice or not yet another
way of distinguishing these searches and
that is it
is it an informed search is it making
use of any kind of heuristic information
certainly a British Museum is not depth
is not breadth is not and now let's
consider what we got for for hill
climbing what do we want to use
backtracking sure what do we want to use
an acute list sure and it is informed
because it's taking advantage of this
extra information may not be in your
problem so it's not often case you've
got this information and map your
problem may not have any university
measurement of distance to the goal
which cases you can't do it but if
you've got it
you should use it oh yeah now there's
one more and I've already kind of given
it away by having it on my chart
it's called beam search and just as hill
climbing is a analog of depth-first
search
beam beam searches is a complement or
addition of an informing heuristic to
breadth-first search so what you do is
you start off just like breadth-first
search but you say i'm going to limit
the number of paths i'm going to
consider at any level to some small
fixed number like in this case how about
two so i'm going to say that i have a
beam width of two for my beam search
otherwise i proceed just like
breadth-first search BD a G and now I've
got that stupid thing where I'm
duplicating my nose because I'm
forgetting about the in queued list but
illustrate beam search what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to take all these
paths I've got at the second level and
I'm only going to keep the best - that's
my beam width the best - or the two that
get closest to the goal so those four B
C a and D which to get closest to the
goal now B and D so these guys are
trimmed off I'm only keeping two at
every level
so now going down from B and D I have at
the next level C and G and now I found
the goal so I'm done we could do that
here too we could choose a beam search
not bad oh but it really let's see let's
try this thing from the middle let's
slow my speed down a little bit now
we're going to see anything going off to
the left like we did with ordinary
breadth-first search no because it's
smart it doesn't say I want to go to a
place that's further away from my goal
all right so now let's see maybe we can
go back to our algorithm now and talk
about that in queuing mechanism
and talk about hill climbing can I use
the babe same basic search mechanism
just change that one line again yes how
do I add a new path of the queue this
time well it's very much like hill
climbing right so I want to add them to
the front but was one little flourish
what's the flourish Krishna what do you
think remember I want to use my
heuristic information so I not only add
them to the front but amongst the ones
I'm adding to the front what do I do
distance and how do you arrange them
yeah so you just you can put the minimum
first if you like but let's sort it me
I'll sort of that'll keep everything
straight
so hill climbing is first uh is front
sort it and finally how about beam what
do we do with beam search to add them to
the queue well it doesn't matter where
we add them because all we're going to
do is we're going to keep the W best
so with beam will just abbreviate that
by saying keep W rest all right
so now you have some of the basic
searches in your toolkit there's one
more that sometimes talked about see we
got depth breadth best and beam one more
is best best first search it's a variant
we when we go on all it's a variant
where you say I've got this tree it's
got a bunch of paths that terminate and
leaves
let me just always work on the leaf node
that's closest to the goal so it can
kind of skip around a little bit from
one place to another because as it
pursues one path it may not do very well
and some other paths quite distant in
the tree will become the best one we've
actually seen the instance of that and
an integration program it's capable of
skipping all over the place because it's
always taking the easiest problem in the
search tree and the end or tree working
on that that's best first search now you
can do these sorts of things and
continue with spaces too and you've done
the mathematics of that in 1802 or
something but in continuous spaces the
hill climbing sometimes leads to
problems or doesn't do very well what
kind of a problem can you encounter in a
continuous space with with hill climbing
well
how would you do hill climbing in
continuous space let's let's say we're
in the mountains and a big fog has come
up trying to get to the top of the hill
before we freeze to death and we take a
few steps north a few steps east west
and south
using our compass and we check to see
which direction seems to be doing the
best job of getting us moving upward and
that's that's our hill climbing approach
right we have explored four directions
we can go and pick the best one then
from there we pick four try all those
pick the best one in the way we go we've
got ourselves a hill climbing algorithm
what's wrong with it what can be wrong
with it sometimes it works just fine yes
and I may get stuck in a local maximum
so problem number from letter A is that
if this is your space may look like that
can you make it stuck on a local maximum
is there any other kind of problem that
can come up
but all depends on what the space is
like here's a problem with the space has
local Maxima now a lot of people been
killed on Mount Washington when the fog
comes up and they do freeze to death why
Hill Climb reason these freezes Athens
they is a hill climbing fails them and
they can't get to the top to the ranger
station and the reason is that there are
large lawns on the shoulders of Mount
Washington quite flat so it's the
telephone pole problem so that space
looks like this oh this isn't what not
Washington looks like but it's it's the
telephone pole problem so when you're
wandering around here the idea of trying
a few directions picking the one that's
best doesn't help any because it's flat
so that can be a problem with hill
climbing now there's one more problem
with hill climbing that most people
don't know about but it works like this
this is a particularly acute problem in
high dimensional space tall straight
here just in two I'm going to switch
from a regular kind of view to a contour
map so my contour map is going to betray
the presence of a sharp bridge along the
45-degree line
and now you see how you can get in
trouble there you get in trouble because
if you take a step in each direction
every direction takes you downhill and
you think you're at the top so suppose
you're right here and you go north that
takes you south over a contour a lot
that takes you down over a contour line
if you go south that also takes you down
over contour lines
likewise going west and east all appear
to be taking you down whereas in fact
you're climbing a ridge and that's that
contour line is the highest that I've
shown so sometimes you can get fooled
not stuck but fooled into thinking
you're at the top when you're actually
not now is this some this is this is a
model of something this this subject is
about modeling intelligence and this is
a kind of algorithm you frequently need
in order to build an intelligent system
but do we have any kind of search
happening in our heads or is this some
is it if we're going to model what goes
on inside our heads too we have to model
any kind of searching in order to do the
kinds of things that we humans do I
suppose so anytime we make a plan we're
actually evaluating a bunch of choices
and seeing how they work let me see if I
can illustrate it another way so this is
a system that I showed you a little bit
of last time and shoot I might as well
review one or two things here I showed
you I make Beth story this is a story I
showed you and if you had this in a
humanities class the simplest questions
you might have might be asked is why did
Macduff kill Macbeth down there at the
bottom that is demonstrate the answering
of questions last time or just the
development of the graph I can't
remember but we'll do it again anyway
so this is some somewhat stylized
English just so you'll know doesn't have
to be stylized English this is the
English that's made available to the
Genesis system by way of something
called a story workbench there's no free
lunch either you can use your human
resources to rewrite the plot in third
grade English or you can use your human
resources to take a more natural adult
high version of the story and decorate
it with annotations that make it
possible to absorb it so just this
summer in a miracle of summer Europe
bread Benzie one of you connected these
two systems together so we can now work
with stories that are expressed in
pretty natural English everything in our
system is to express in English
including common sense knowledge like if
somebody kills you you're dead but more
more importantly for today's
illustration that reflective level
knowledge that knowledge about what
revenge is so here you are in that
you're in the manatees class and someone
says what's really going on in the story
not the details of who kills whom
but is there a Pyrrhic victory does
somebody have a success is there an act
of revenge right these are all kinds of
things you might be asked about in some
kind of humanities class so let me fire
up the Genesis system
pray for Internet connectivity
launched the system on a read of that
Macbeth story that I showed you a moment
ago at the moment it's absorbing
information about background knowledge
and about reflective level knowledge and
all that sort of thing
it's building itself this thing we call
an elaboration graph not quite there yet
it's still reading background knowledge
now it's reading Macbeth it's building
its elaboration graph same thing you saw
last time except except not quite see
that stuff down at the bottom those are
higher-level concepts that it's managed
to find and the Macbeth story so it's
found a revenge how did it do that it
searched it had a description of
whatever avenges and a look to see if
that pattern was exhibited in the
elaboration graph so in a combination of
things that were said explicitly and
things that were produced by knee-jerk
if-then rules the elaboration graph was
sufficiently instantiated that the
revenge pattern could be found that's
interesting Pyrrhic victory is a little
harder you probably get an A if you said
oh there's a Pyrrhic victory in here now
there it is so blow that up a little bit
so you can see what it is you know what
Pyrrhic victory is it's something it's a
situation where everything seems to be
going good at first and then not so hot
so make Beth wants to be king down here
and eventually that leads to becoming
King but too bad for Macbeth because
eventually he gets killed in consequence
so it's a period victory all that
produced by search programs are looking
through this graph now once you've got
the capable of doing that of course then
you can find all sorts of things and you
can report them in English but more
interestingly you can ask answer
questions so I did
Mack that cares not a hoot about
capitalization on a common-sense level
it looks like dr. general thanks Macduff
kills Macbeth because Matt Bevin Gers
Macduff on a reflective level it looks
like dr. gentle thanks Mick does killed
Macbeth is part of X of mistake
birra victory and revenge pretty corny
speech output but you see the point how
did they get this stuff on the common
sense level same way all of those
programs that bill goal trees report
answers to questions it's just looking
locally around and the connections in
the goal tree how do they get the stuff
on the reflective level by reporting on
the searches that produced information
it does that by looking for higher-level
thoughts about its own thoughts and
reporting in which of those higher-level
thoughts the incident and to ask about
actually occurs so let's see just for
fun we might be interested in why
Macbeth murdered
Danka let this be handy if you hadn't
actually read the play and here it is
you got to write that paper on common
sense level it looks like I'll pull the
plug on that because that's just
annoying yeah pretty good Macbeth wants
to be king and Duncan is the king so
let's see why do they make Beth become
king
oh yeah oh I won't answer the question
unless I spell it right
okay that wouldn't be I wouldn't be able
to show that to you last until last
spring in fact I would have been able to
show you this today until last week with
a tweak this morning because we've just
now connected the speech output the the
language output to Boris's parser system
which is running in Reverse in order to
generate that English so that's
something that has never before been
seen by any eyes with me and so that
will conclude what we have to do today
you